I have lard Dominguez here
congratulations what a game you beat
sish giri with black pieces but it all
started with this G move and you spend
like 10 minutes thinking what to play
tell us a little bit about that yeah I
wasn't expecting uh something like this
um so I thought good we'll have some
kind of original game U probably from
the start and that's more or less what
we got so I was in Creative creative
move more or less I play decided to play
this H5 but it was very interesting
position yeah I I wasn't sure how to
evaluate it I felt that black was doing
all right but uh yeah there were many
many uh possibilities and and it was
hard during the game to know what what
was going on but yeah once uh of course
I think the critical moment was when he
plays C3 and then allow me this queen G3
from that moment on I felt that I was
very close to to victory yeah I mean so
where did you really actually start like
and what was the moment you start like
like your position I felt that after
this um in this position yeah it was
more or less balanced but I I didn't see
um I didn't think I was better to be
honest so I thought some move here
because maybe if he goes uh Queen B5 I
can play Queen B4 and take CB and this
end game it's probably fine I always
have this idea maybe to play ight H7 9
G5 eventually and and black has some
potential but I thought if white goes
some move like A3 instead of this um it
should be maybe around equal no not here
but instead of queen5 inste Queen I see
uh but yeah I felt that uh that I was
doing fine maybe not more than that but
uh but yeah after C3 definitely um I saw
I mean I saw this queen G3 and and queen
C5 I mean it's not the same exchange now
you have this pones
right um I was wondering if you noticed
that you made the move number 40 with
one second on I realized yeah but you
were tickling our nerves you know we
were yeah no I I I thought I had time
but then I looked and I had one second
so really at the moment you looked it
you had one second so you had to make so
I didn't I mean it's not like I saw when
I had one second and I play fast so I
made the move thinking I have time and
when I looked I had 31 so thanks God it
worked this way imagine when winning
like this yeah it would have been sad
but yeah it's uh
um in that moment you feel a little
strange yeah because okay so so close to
but then it's uh it's just over and
believe believe me we also felt very
strange we couldn't believe our eyes
anyway so after that actually what you
were thinking about this moment let's
say you were choosing between the moves
I guess
yes um I thought Rook G8 was very direct
because so he cannot play Rook G2 but
then Rook C2 and uh yeah finally I
thought I don't have to yeah this is
also winning of course check and Knight
D5 with the idea Rook G2 yeah it's
completely winning and I felt that I
should uh win more or less with any move
that doesn't position torture him yes
why to win quickly let's tort yeah
should have played it faster of course
but yeah after m 40 I I realized that
white is basically lost here there
there's no no chance because I have um
such a good coordination that um the BS
are just simply too far there's no way
to to fight them yeah um finally victory
in the tournament after so many draws
how does it feel yeah it feels great
yeah of course to win to win a game at
this level and especially with black
it's uh it's a big deal so I'll I'll
enjoy it and and keep going did you feel
anything special today in in the playing
Hall I mean three games almost probably
will finish decisively was it like T
tension special tension today no I mean
I was just really into trying to focus
on my game but yeah at some point I did
see that uh that probably today uh
there's a lot of of blood somehow and um
yeah but it's good I mean it was it was
about about time to for it to happen
yeah maybe after free day what did you
do yeah know I was just uh relaxing try
to trying to save energy and uh not
really preparing much and yeah I was
kind of right because G3 would have
killed in any case all preparation so it
was good good decision yeah thank you
Lor so much and all the best of luck in
the next round thank you thank you
indeed our congratulations lanir